[Music]
I've never tried ripping an apple in
half with my bare hands I think you're
understating how you can't no way can't
know what we're doing today this is
challenge accepted I'm thinking that I'm
gonna try to make some incisions with
this dud right here think I'm gonna try
to use my nails
that's a Caesar nail so hey so far your
fingers like at the top yeah where the
holes are that's not working though so
there's a little bit of a hole oh wow
that's quite the noise I just crushed it
I feel like pressing it is easy oh my
god no oh I heard the crack I don't have
never heard of this what white in what
scenario would you need this yeah it's
just like Jesus Christ upon it oh my god
if you get this oh my god he's stronger
than I am I'm not breaking my fingers Oh
oh my god the first step remove all
stickers
how did grip it he like he gripped it
like this oh my god please do that are
you certain Oh dip at the bottom right
not to break some nails I'm doing the
paw my god oh my god
I feel like it's a new party trick good
god no I will not take this to parties I
will never do this again
oh my god we need to carry an apple I
would like to be able to do it at
parties but clearly absolutely not know
if there's alcohol involved maybe but
but you know what on a crazy drunken
night if there's an apple nearby I'm
gonna tell people I just like I could
rip that Apple in half with my bare
hands I might just prove myself worthy -
we're gonna eat all of these apples
definitely at least I can still dip this
part in peanut butter I'm gonna heat the
whole damn thing Sasha this calls for a
toast
cheers [ __ ] mmm